[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى نقاش الملف الاول تلميح
وموافقه حاضره جاءت من طهران ومن اعلى
سلطه فيها المرشد الايراني علي خامنئي
يكشف عدم ممنعته بتوصل طهران الى اتفاق مع
الغرب حول انشطتها النوويه بشرط الا يتم
المساس ببنيته النوويه كما قال تصريح هذا
ياتي بعد ايام من نفي طهران و واشنطن صحه
تقرير ذكر انهما يقتربان من ابرام اتفاق
المؤقت تقلص سهران بموجبه من برنامجها
النووي مقابله تخفيف العقوبات لكنها
خامنئي في تصريحاته جدد موقف بلاده بعدم
السعي لصنع قنبله نوويه لافتا الى ان
الغرب لن يستطيع منعها اي منع ايران اذا
ارادت ذلك ورغم طلبه من السلطات الايرانيه
عدم الرضوخ الى ما اسماها بالمطالب
المبالغ فيها والخاطئه للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه دعا هيئه الطاقه الذريه
لمواصلات العمل مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
في اطار من الضمانات بدوره اكد المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ان اي اتفاق سيتم
التواصل اليه بشان الملف النووي سيحمي
مصالح ايران وسيراعي الخطوط الحمراء كما
قال موضحا ان بلاده لا تجرم بحثاه لابرام
اتفاق النووي مؤقت او جديد وان اي تفاوض
يجب ان يرتكز على اساس اتفاق 2015 من
جانبها احجمات الخارجيه الامريكيه عن
الادلاء باي تعليق حول تصريحات الايرانيه
كذلك هناك بعض التفاصيل الاخرى حيث جددت
التزامها عدم السماح لايران بامتلاك اي
سلاح نووي
ابرز تصريحات واشنطن وطهران بشان الاتفاق
النووي مايو 2022
المبعوث الامريكي الخاص بشان ايران فرص
احياء الاتفاق ضعيفه
مستعده لتجديد العقوبات
سبتمبر 2022 الخارجيه الايرانيه مقاربتنا
بناء لانهاء المفاوضات
2022 الخارجيه الايرانيه لن تحصل امريكا
واوروبا على تنازلات في المفاوضات النوويه
عبر الضغوط يونيو 2023 الخارجيه الامريكيه
واشنطن تفضل النهجه الدبلوماسي لتقييد
قدرات اراده نوويه وفي حال الفشل
فالخيارات مطروحه
مناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن بشار
جرار الكاتب والمحلله السياسي
ومن طهران محمد صالح صادق يان المحلل
السياسي اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام وقبل البدء
بمناقشه كل هذه التطورات لفهم كذلك هذه
المرحله هل هي مرحله تقارب هل هي مرحله
تباعد هل نحن امام تحضير لشيء جديد اسمحوا
لي في البدايه ان نذكر ببعض التصريحات
تصريحات للمرشده الايراني علي خمنئ
تصريحات كذلك المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
كما تعلمون هناك حديث عن موقف ايران من
الغرب في علاقه بالاتفاق النووي وهنا كذلك
حديث عن ضمانات عن مطالب تطلبها ايران
نذكر بهذه التصريحات ونبدا النقاش
يجب عدم المساس بالبنيه التحتيه للصناعه
النوويه خلال هذه السنوات قام المديرون
والمسؤولون والناشطون في هذه الصناعه
باعمال مهمه وانشاوا بنيه تحتيه كبيره قد
ترغبون في عقد اتفاقيات في بعض المجالات
النوويه لا توجد مشكله اتفقوا لكن لا
ينبغي المساس بالبنت التحتيه ولا ينبغي ان
تتضرر يجب احترامها فهذه هي نتائج جهود
الاخرين
لن نقبل باتفاق مؤقت لقد تبادلنا الرسائل
مع الاطراف المتفاوضه عبر سلطنه عمان لا
نوافق على اي مفاوضات لابرام اتفاق مؤقت
يحل محل الاتفاق النووي السابق نحن نعتبر
هذه المزاعم التكهنات اعلاميه او انباء
تروج لها اطراف بدوافع سياسيه او لتعكير
مسار عمليه المفاوضات الحاليه
ارحب جديده من جديد بضيوفي الكرام
واسمحولي ان ابدا من طهران معك استاذ
صادقيان ولنبدا وندخل مباشره في جوهر
الموضوع بتصريحات المتحدث في الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني التي يقول فيها
بانه لن نقبل ايران لن تقبل باتفاق مؤقت
باتفاق جديد
نتحاور او نتفاوض بما يتناسب مع مطالبنا
طيب ولكن في المقابل سيد صادقيان تعلم
حضرتك بانه واشنطن
دستوريا لا يمكن ان تضمن ان مثلا ان ياتي
رئيس جديد ولا ان ينسحب وان لا ينسحب من
اتفاق النووي يعني جديد قادره ان تتواصل
عليه الاطراف اعتبر مراقبون بان هذه
التصريحات لايران هي تصريحات تعجيزيه كيف
ترى حضرتك الموضوع
مساء الخير اهلا بك وللمشاهدين يعني عندما
سمعنا المرشد الايراني اعلى الامام
الخامنئي عندما قال بانه يوافق على اتفاق
بشرط ان
بشرط صيانه البنى التحتيه النوويه في
ايران فهم بان او ربما البعض فهم بان
المرشد الاعلى يعني يقبل اي اتفاق مع
الولايات المتحده بشان البرنامج الايرانيه
وما عرف بالاتفاق المؤقت لكن المصادر قالت
بعد ذلك كل يوم اكد ذلك المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الايرانيه هو قال بان من لا يوجد
اتفاق مؤقت لا نقبل باي اتفاق بديل عن
الاتفاق النووي الموقع عام 2015
وبالتالي المرشد كان يتحدث حول اتفاق بين
ايران والوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
بانه تحدث ايضا عن صيانه البرنامج النووي
الايراني والبنى التحتيه
ولكن خليني واسمح لي ان نبدا بتصريحات
ناصر كنعاني هو كان يتحدث عن الغرب كان
يتحدث عن امكانيه العوده لمفاوضات بناء
على عدم تراجع مثلا من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه واشار الى ذلك في كلامه طيب كيف
ستضمن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهي في
قانونها في دستورها لا يمكن ان يلزم رئيس
رئيس قادم فيما بعد بان يتمسك وان لا
ينسحب من اي اتفاق المفترض
هي هذه المشكله هاي المشكله التي اوقعت
الاتفاق النووي في هذا
المازق الذي هو فيه حاليا الكل يعلم بان
ايران عندما دخلت مع الولايات المتحده
سواء في عهد الرئيس الايراني السابق حسن
روحانيه او في عهد الرئيس الايراني الحالي
ابراهيم رئيسي تم الاتفاق على كل الامور
بما في ذلك صفقه تبادل المعتقلين بين
جانبين لكن المشكله عندما طالب الجانب
الايراني ضمانات بان يبقى هذا الاتفاق سعر
المفعول حتى وان تغير
لكن لم يتم ذلك لم يتم ذلك لانه ليس هناك
امكانيه تقول واشنطن لذلك وطالما حضرتك
تعتبر بان هذه مشكله خلينا ننقل هذه
النقطه الاستاذ بشار استاذ بشار الكل يقر
بان هذه مشكله حقيقيه ايران تطالب بان
تكون هناك ضمانات وابرز هذه الضمانات ان
لا ينسحب رئيس قادم من اتفاق مفترض
واشنطن تقول بانه في قانوني في دستوري لا
يمكنني ان الزم رئيسا قادم بذلك هل تعتقد
بانه ايران اذا كان يقر سيد صديق بانها
مشكله هي تناور ما الذي تريده من فرض هكذا
ضمان مره والاخرى
المشكله قابله للحل بما ان هناك في رغبه
بالتفاوض ولكن هي معضله ولا يعني ليست
مساله تسميات القضيه مرتبطه لسفقه الدستور
الامريكي وان النظام السياسي الامريكي
النظام مرتبط بسلطه رئاسيه تنفيذيه الرئيس
هو الذي يقرر هذه الملفات سياسه الخارجيه
وسياسات الدفاع وان كانت قضيه الحرب
والسلام بيد الكونغرس عن النظام السياسي
ولكن اليس كذلك الدستور الامريكي يمنح
رئيسا جديدا امكانيه ان ينسحب من معاهدات
من اتفاقيه دوليه اذا كان هذا يتعلق
بالامن القومي الامريكي صحيح
صحيح مئه بالمئه ولكن هذا ما اردت الربط
في فيما يتعلق في جزئيات تعني الملف
النووي الايراني او اتفاق 2015 لان
المساله ليست فقط سياسه خارجيه المساله
متعلقه
بالعلاقه مع الحلفاء حلفاء موجودين في
المنطقه على راس هاي اسرائيل
الخليجيه خاصه السعوديه وهي ايضا في صميم
الامن القومي الامريكي وهذا كله يعطي
الرئيس الامريكي ايا كان من اي اداره كانت
يعطيه القوه للتحرك وللضغط حتى لو كان
الكونجرس بمجلسيه لم يكن مع هذه الاداره
الان بايدن مشكلته بان هذه الاداره
الثالثه لاوباما لديها مجلس نواب لدى
الحزب الاخر هو الحزب الجمهوري ولديه ايضا
السنه مجلس الشيوخ باغلبيه ضعيفه صوت واحد
عمليا وهو لا يمتلك القوه الكافيه من
الناحيه التشريعيه لتمرير اي اتفاق وهذا
يعني ان بايدن مضطر مضطر لان يزود الاداره
والكونغرس بقرار والحلفاء ايضا بمعنى
اسرائيل السعوديه الامارات ودول الخليج
يزودها بقرار
هذه الخلاصه بهذا الاتفاق سيحفظ مصالح
الجميع هذه هي الموضله
وهذه معضله كبيره في الواقع منذ اتفاق
2015 ولكن سيد صادقيان مع ما تفضل به ضيفي
هناك كذلك معضله الوقت نحن مقبلون على
انتخابات امريكيه جديده انتخابات 2024 هل
تعتقد سيد صادقيان من وجهه نظر حضرتك
وقراءتك للاوضاع بان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ستسرع في ايجاد حل الاتفاق
النووي او بالعكس هذا الموضوع مؤجل لما
بعد هذه الانتخابات
دعينا نقتنع جميعا بان اداره الرئيس بايدن
اداره ضعيفه متردده وهي لا تريد ان او لا
تستطيع او لا تريد ان تتخذ قرارات حاسمه
بالتالي صحيح ان الكونغرس
معك الاستاذ بشار في هذا الخصوص ولكن
استاذ بشار اسمح لي كذلك اسمح لي كذلك ان
نتفاعل ونذكر ساعود
الجمهور ترامب هو الذي انسحب من الاتفاق
النووي ساعود لك في خصوص هذه النقطه ولكن
اكمل فكره حضرتك سيد صادقين
المشكله ان الرئيس بايدن لديه صلاحيات
رئاسيه يمكن ان يفعلها
والرئيس بايدن هو قال قبل الانتخابات التي
فاز بها هو قال بانه يريد العوده الى
الاتفاق النووي وان ترامب خطا خطا جسيما
عندما انسحب من هذا الاتفاق بعد ذلك
المفاوضات التي بدات مباشره بعد فوز
الرئيس بايدن لم تستطع اداره بايدن من
عمليا من تحقيق هذه الاهداف او من تحقيق
هدف الرئيس بايدن بالرجوع الى الاتفاق
النووي
بقينا نسمع تداعيات واستحقاقات الانتخابات
النصفيه الان بعد الانتخابات النصفيه هناك
انتخابات العام المقبل عشرين اربعه وعشرين
وبالتالي انا اعتقد بان الرئيس بايدن اذا
كان يريد ان يعمل بجديه وهذه الضغوط
الاقليميه التي تحدث عنها الاستاذ بشار هي
موجوده ايضا كانت في عهد الرئيس باراك
اوباما لكنه قال بان الاتفاق مع ايران يحد
من الطموحات الايرانيه ولذلك وقع مع ايران
الاتفاق النووي عام 2015 الان هناك
صلاحيات عند الرئيس بايدن لم يستخدمها
يستطيع ان
هذه الصلاحيات من اجل العوده الى الاتفاق
2015 لكن كما قلت بان الاداره ضعيفه
ومتردده وضحت هذه النقطه صحيح نعم او
صلاحيهم باختصار شديد قبل ان انتقل الى
واشنطن معك استاذ بشار سيد صادقين اليس من
الغريب ان تلقي باللوم على اداره بايدن في
ضعفها في التعامل ترجع حتى وتعود الى
اداره اوباما ولكن لا تتحدث عن اداره
ترامب ولا تنسحبت من الاتفاق النووي حضرتك
يبدو بانك ايراني ولكن تسند الجمهوريين
لا لا بالتاكيد يعني خطا
السيد ترامب وقع في خطا كبير جدا هذا
الخطا هو ضرب الولايات المتحده قبل ان يضر
بايران واضر بحلفاء الولايات المتحده قبل
ان يضر بايران الان بعد اكثر من خمس سنوات
من انسحاب الامريكي من الاتفاق النووي ما
الذي حدث ايران كانت تخص باليورانيوم 3.7
الان تخص باليورانيوم 60% والوكاله
الدوليه تقول بانها وجدت عينات بالتخصيب
اليورانيوم بنسبه 83% هل هذا انجاز
حققه السيد ترامب او حققته الولايات
المتحده او انتفعت منه حلف ارتفع منه
حلفاء الولايات المتحده في المنطقه وضحت
هذه نقطه ان كان لك تعليق في خصوص ما كنا
نتحدث به استاذ بشار
هذا يظهر ان ترامب كان يفهم حقيقه بيجري
ان السلوك هو المشكله ليس موضوع حتى هذه
النسبه التي رسمها عليها خط احمر الرئيس
وزراء اسرائيل نتنياهو في اداراته السابقه
عندما قال ان هناك خط لا نستطيع الصمت او
الصبر حتى تمتلك السلاح النووي المشكله هي
في السلوك الايراني وهو يثبت حتى باعتراف
الضيف ولكن الكريم الطهران ان هناك مراوغه
هناك حتى النسب التي التزمت بها اختلفت
بمعنى ان اسقطت ترامب من يدي ادارات
اوباما باداره بايدن هذه المقوله التي
خدعوا فيها الراي العام الامريكي والعالمي
باننا يجب ان نبقى بالاتفاق 2015 حتى نعلم
ماذا يجري في ايران وتبين ان هذا الامر
غير صحيح على الاطلاق المشكله هي في
السلوك وهنا دعيني التقط ما قاله خامرئي
في البدايه وللامانه هذه اول مره رمز
الممانعه لا يمانع هذا جديد بالخطاب
السياسي والاعلامي الايراني وهو يفرح
للامانه عندما يقول انه لا يمانع باتفاق
يحفظي الكلمات المستخدمه يحفظ البنيه
التحتيه وكانها يقول الاتفاق هو في الاساس
سيكون مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
بمعنى الفصل بين مسارين وهذا هو كان هدف
ترامب الفصل بين السلوك وبين القدرات
النوويه
والصاروخيه ايضا هو يقول هذا الملف سيتولى
المؤسسه الدوليه وهي وكاله دوليه الطاقه
الذريه والمجتمع الدولي ولكن الملف
السياسي يبقى بيد من هو في واشنطن ويعلم
بايدن انه لا مجال له للبت في اي صفقه
المغرب قد يكون بشيء من الانترنت بمعنى
انتقالي مرحلي يستطيع ان يسوقوا للناخب
الامريكي بالحزمه الديمقراطي بانه تمكن من
صنع ناصر الدبلوماسي لم يتحقق طبعا لن
يخدع بذلك اي احد لكن استاذ بشار هل حضرتك
تشير الى اننا يمكن ان نكون امام اتفاقين
او اتفاق كبير وملحق مثلا ما رايك في هذا
الكلام سيتصدقيان هل فعلا ايران تنوي طرح
طرح مثل هكذا فكره بان يكون هناك اتفاق
يخص تخصيب اليورانيوم الانتاج كل ما هو
تقني مع الاداره الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
ولكن كل ما يخص السلوك يكون شيء ملحق بهذا
الاتفاق الكبير ربما تتشارك فيه دول معنيه
دول الخليج كانت تطالب بان تكون حاضره
بابداء راي فيما يخص هذا الموضوع
هذا هو هناك مسارين المسار الاول التي
تتعامل معه ايران مع الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه وهناك رغده ايرانيه جامحه
بحل كل المشاكل العالقه بين الجانبين وهذا
ما اشار اليه
المرشد الايراني الاعلى السيد الخامنئي
عندما قال بانه لا يمانع بحل كافه المشاكل
مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه هناك
مسار اخر وهو مسار المفاوضات النوويه
استئنافها في فيينا او في عمان او في اي
مكان اخر هذه المفاوضات انا اعتقد بان
الاتفاق الاتفاق الموقع عام 2015 قد
استنفذت اغراضه حاليا العقوبات ايضا ايران
استطاعت ان تتجاوز العقوبات الان نحن امام
معادلات
جديده وهناك تاريخ كذلك تغيرت فيه الكثير
من الامور وايران خاصبت فيه بما يصل حتى
منذ قليل تحدث عن 83 هناك من تحدث حتى عن
86 90 تمكنها من البدء بالعمل على تحقيق
او انجاز قنبله نوويه ولكن لماذا ان كنت
حضرتك ترى بانه استنفذ اتفاق 2015 لماذا
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر
كنعان يقول بانه لا ننتظر شيء جديد او شيء
مؤقت نحن سنعمل بالارتكاز على اساس 2015
لا يوجد لدى ايران حيله اخرى الاتفاق
المؤقت لا يعطي حاجات ايران الضروريه وهي
ازاله كافه العقوبات التي فرضت على ايران
على خلفيه البرنامج النووي الايراني
وبالتالي الشيء الوحيد الموجود حاليا هو
اتفاق 2015 الذي اودع لدى مجلس الامن
الدولي وصدر بحقه القرار الامم المرقم 220
31 وبالتالي ايران لا زالت تسر على تنفيذ
الاتفاق 22 واحد وثلاثين وهذه رساله او
مرسله الى الجانب الاوروبي من اجل تفعيل
اليه انستكس التي وضعها الاوروبيون من اجل
التعامل الاقتصادي والتجاري وتعامل المالي
استاذ بشار وكان حضرتك لم تقتنع بمقوله
ضيفي بان ايران لا تملك حلول اخرى
اعلم ان المفاوض الايراني
لا يظهر دائما امام الاعلام ما يبطن من
اتفاقات ونذكر الاجواء التي كانت في 2015
كيف اكثر من مره كانت تصل الامور الى
انهيار والتهديد بالتصعيد وانها ستضرب
بالازرق على الموجوده من ميليشيات في
المنطقه وتحق الان في الوقت الذي تكون فيه
بكين ضامنه لاتفاق تطبيع العلاقات بين
السعوديه وايران هل يعتقد اي عاقل بان
الاجواء تتجه الى تصعيد في الموضوع الملف
النووي الايراني وبالتالي الصدام مع
اسرائيل وامريكا وعدد من دول الخليج قطعا
ولكن سيد بشار اذا كانت الامور لا تتوجه
لا تتجه نحو التصعيد هل تعتقد حضرتك بان
جو بايدن فيما تبقى فيما تبقى له طبعا من
فتره لولايته سيقتنص الفرصه للاسراع بطرح
شيء فعلي ينسب للديمقراطيين نعم هو يهرول
لان الوقت بالفعل ليس من صالحه اوله هو
مهدد
بمعنى العزل على ضوء عديد من الملفات
الفضائيه الداخليه هو ايضا مهدد بضغط
اسرائيلي وعدد من دول الخليجيه ونقل صراحه
السعوديه بشكل مباشر بانه لن تقبل باتفاق
لا يكون الا مراعيا للمصالح الامنيه
والدفاعيه والاقتصاديه للدول المنطقه وليس
امريكي ايراني النقطه الثالثه وهي في غايه
الخطوره ان كثيرا من الاوراق هذه الملفات
الان يا سيدتي بيدي موسكو وهناك مشكله في
اوكرانيا فلا يمكن ان تتعاون موسكو الا في
التوصل الى تفاهمات ما ولن تنحصر بالموضوع
الايراني وانما ستجمل الاوكراني ايضا
باختصار شديد وصادقيان اختم معك بتصريح
علي خمينائي المرشد الايراني والذي بدات
بها حضرتك واشارت له في حديقه لما توجه
للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه وقال بانه
يمكن ان نتفاوض على شيء معين دون المساس
بالبناء التحتيه البعض استغرب طيب البنى
التحتيه لم تكن موجوده في الاول لماذا يعد
طرحها الان هل بني شيء جديد في السنوات
الاخيره تخاف ايران من طرحه من كشفه من ان
يفضح
هناك تصور بان قد تطلب الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه مثلا تدمير
اجهزه الطرد المركزي التي تستطيع ان تخصب
60% البعض الاخر يعني اعتقد بان ربما تطلب
الوكاله الدوليه ايضا من
تدمير بعض المواقع النوويه الايرانيه او
المنشات النوويه الايرانيه المرشد
الايراني الاعلى هو اراد التاكيد على هذه
على هذه الثوابت على البنى التحتيه
النوويه وهو قال بشكل واضح بان قوه ايران
من قوه برنامجها النووي وبالتالي هو هذا
كان معروف ايضا بان السيد الخامنئي هو
يقول بان احد اسباب قوه ايران هو البرنامج
النووي الايراني دون اللجوء الى
تصنيع السلاح النووي او القنبله الذريه
وبالتالي الان نحن نعرف مدى
رهبه اسرائيل من البرنامج النووي الايراني
الذي تعتقد بانه يستطيع ان يجعل ايران
قويه
بما تؤهله لها هذا البرنامج النووي في
مجالات متعدده تقنيه وعلميه واكاديميه
وكذلك يقول باننا لا نطمح لصالح نووي لان
هذا يتعارض مع عقيداتنا الدينيه هكذا هذه
نقطه كذلك يمكن ان نناقشها ولكن في فترات
لاحقه او شكركم جزيل الشكر على المشاركه
من واشنطن بشر جرار الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ومن طهران محمد صالح صادقيان
المحلله السياسي شكرا لكما
نتوقف مع فاصل ما بعد سنعود لنناقش في
ملفنا ثاني
بعد شهور من الترقب الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد انطلق بمكاسب محدوده هل بدات
استراتيجيه ثياب العسكريه تحقق اهدافها
وكيف تخطط موسكو الرد
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات